a large double-engine aircraft just flew
into the World Trade Center this idea of
ramming an aircraft into a building it
wasn't on our radar screen
I was now the National Security advisor
on a day of the worst attack on American
territory since the war of 1812.
American 11 767 possible hijacked
football departures stop all departures
in a crisis like this it's really
all-consuming there is a lot that you
don't know and there's a lot that you
think you know that is wrong
vice president Cheney then turned to me
and said the president has authorized a
shoot down of an aircraft
it was hijacked it represented a true
threat
the president didn't have time to go
through the pros and cons every plane
that was in the air was a potential
missile
when 93 went down
whole moment where we all thought that
perhaps we'd shot it down